maxime thibeault justement cette
manifestation qui se déroule que l'on
voit ici place de la république
on approche du moment de la dispersion
cette manifestation elle a été dûment
enregistrés auprès de la préfecture de
police qui ne l'a pas interdit en
revanche elle a interdit la
manifestation des gilet jaune
j'ai devant moi d'ailleurs le communiqué
de presse
plusieurs raisons à cette interdiction d
gilet de cette manifestation du gilet
jaune
les mesures d'hygiène distanciation
sociale les risques de troubles à
l'ordre public
sk pas là deux poids deux mesures on a
du mal à comprendre je pense pas
sincèrement je pense pas je pense que la
préfecture elle a joué aussi
l'efficacité des manifestations c'est à
dire qu'elle sait très bien que les
gilets jaunes allait pouvoir se
retrouver dans la marche des libertés
non honnêtement là je vois pas
d'intention négative de la part de la
préfecture sur cette interdiction
je voulais rebondir par rapport à ce que
disait monsieur vallières était très
juste sur les années soixante dix et les
manifestations dans les années 70 il est
vrai t'as violence était beaucoup plus
forte
les différences avec ce qu'on connaît
aujourd'hui c'était à l'époque on
n'avait pas de diffusion en direct des
manifestations donc la violence qu'elle
soit des manifestants ou de la police
ils violence légitime comme violences
policières
elles n'étaient pas filmés elle n'était
pas directement partager sur les réseaux
sociaux dont elles étaient moins
visibles et donc la population a moins
été touché par ces violences da voyez
plutôt dans le jt le soir et puis les
images étaient quand même filtrer une
telle différence est quand même
importante et il y avait un objet de
violences aussi de la part des
manifestantes étaient différents c'est à
dire que en effet des classes populaires
les classes ouvrières devait montrer
leur virilité ville et a montré qu'il se
battait pour leurs droits sociaux mais
il y avait une sorte de violence
respectueux entre à la fois les
policiers et puis manifestants parce que
à la fin de cette traction chacun rentre
chez soi et les les ouvriers entrent lit
mais étaient dans le respect de ce qui
se passe aujourd'hui avec les black
blocks avec les casseurs orgue
knees et moi je distingue le manifestant
qui est un moment pète un câble et tape
sur les policiers qui lui doit être
réprimée je ne distingue du black blocks
et du du casseur d'y organiser des
strings gauche
ces gens là sont dans une logique de
troubles troubles graves pardon à
l'ordre public ils sont dans une logique
d'attaquer l'état de droit ils veulent
détruire l'état en montant les français
les uns contre les autres et quand il ya
des lego des troubles graves à l'ordre
public
le code pénal prévoit de pouvoir
attaquer ces organisations et ces
personnes c'est le chapitre relatif aux
actes terroristes ou le terrorisme et il
est disposé dans le code pénal qu'on
peut poursuivre des gens qui ont des
associations qui troublent gravement
l'ordre public et je remarque que le
parquet comme le ministre de l'intérieur
monsieur dupont moretti ne font
strictement rien pour mettre en oeuvre
ces dispositions pénales et puis voir
réellement s'attaquer aux blacks blocks
qui dénaturent les manifestations parce
que si on était sous ce régime là celui
du terrorisme on pourrait faire des
préventions des de la police
administrative préventive en pouvant
faire des perquisitions pouvant faire
des choses en demandant aux casseurs
reconnu au black blocks qui sont fichés
s de rester chez eux et en leur
interdisant de venir à la manifestation
et alors on pourrait réduire comme ça la
pression des blagues note on pourrait
réduire les violences
mais ce qui risque de se passer si on
réduit la violence c'est que la colère
la colère les discours le fond du
message les revendications populaires
sont davantage entendu parler français
et là le gouvernement serait
malheureusement me serais gêné parce
qu'on ne verrait plus à la télé le soir
les violences mais on verrait le fond du
discours le fond des manifestations on
entendrait ce que ce que sont les
revendications et ça que je pense mais
je trouve que nous sommes enfin que vous
dites c'est que finalement ça
arrangerait le gouvernement cesser ces
violences qui sont le fait de casseurs
qui implique reçu les manifestations la
bloque ce sont les meilleurs alliés du
ministère de l'intérieur et du
gouvernement
pourquoi parce que ils permettent de ne
pas parler des revendications
donc si monsieur darmanin s'il gouverne
on voulait réellement bêtement d'un bloc
si le coup il a le renseignement qui lui
permet de savoir qui sont ces personnes
ils savent comment ils sont organisés
pour ce qui est des réseaux de squats
etc
donc il pourrait mettre en oeuvre tous
les outils juridiques il est neutralisé
le problème si tu le sont pas parce que
les blacks leurs leçons
mais c'est l'intérêt de du gouvernement
du ministère de l'intérieur de montrer
aux français chaque semaine que ce n'est
pas possible de maîtriser la situation
et de lutter contre ce phénomène des
black blocks mais c'est son intérêt
qu'on parle pas du fou des problèmes
c'est son intérêt qu'on ne parle pas des
privations de liberté pendant train de
connaître notamment avec le code 19 ou
avec la le projet la proposition de loi
sécurité globale le but c'est de ne pas
parler de ce que fait le gouvernement je
sais pas si vous avez remarqué mais
depuis des semaines on nous fait peur
surtout les sur tous les pans on nous
fait peur avec les black blocks en nous
disant attention votre sécurité est
remise en cause
ils vont casser vos commerces y sont
partout etc et on lui fait peur avec le
club il en me lisant faux culs embrassés
mais mes faux culs roi cpp parce que
vous allez les rendre malades
donc les gens sont tétanisés et quand on
est tétanisé on ne réfléchit plus les
cantons bref mais chez vous on va se
diriger vers la place de la république
pour rejoindre par la situation sur le
point sur place de la république sur les
tensions on voit qu'il ya une atmosphère
lac etc et n'est pas très tendue on va
voir ça avec nos reporters mais cette
dernière question qui concerne
évidemment cette loi sécurité globale
qui mobilise la rue la rue qui persiste
et signe
chaque semaine ça va aller jusqu'où à
votre avis
ça va aller moi je pense que le soda
allé jusqu'à l'épuisement c'est à dire
que je pense que les gens ont continué
de manifester puis tout à petit les fai
devront passer par là et puis bah ça va
compter c'est un peu comme les chiffres
des jaunes s'il vous plaît et gilet
jaune c'était tout le peuple français
qui est un bonbon serrer les miches des
gens partout en france
et puis progressivement sa s'est réuni à
quelques groupuscules et puis bon sens
et ça s'est dispersée mais je pense que
c'est ce qui va se passer
en attendant à tous les projets de loi
qui sont liberticides et propositions de
lois qu'on ne peut pas battre ont passé
la manifestation contiennent pas si bien
que ça merci à vous maxima thiébaut au
docteur en droit public mer